la voici la voilà une cérémonie des
césar qui laissera un drôle de goût si
le joli film d'abdellatif kechiche raflé
quatre trophées en revanche les deux
favoris de la soirée les choristes et un
long dimanche de fiançailles ont été
quasiment oubliés du palmarès oublié
aussi benoît poelvoorde pourtant favori
dans son rôle formidable de podium
compte rendu de la soirée marie jo
jouant et sébastien laffargue merci à
ccc un prix qu'on partage avec toute une
équipe
l'émotion d'abdellatif kechiche le
réalisateur de l'esquivé la victoire de
david contre goliath
quatre césars meilleur film meilleur
réalisateur meilleur scénario et
meilleur espoir féminin pour l'héroïne
de cette histoire les lycéens qui
découvre ma vie de votre
leskiw réalisé avec des bouts de ficelle
le meilleur espoir féminin
est attribué à sara forestier
enfile retiré des écrans parce qu'il ne
faisait pas assez d'entrée
ce césar
c'est une reconnaissance de tout notre
travail à tous à toutes les personnes
qui ont travaillé sur ce film
et que je suis contente
génial autre surprise de la soirée non
cet amas de londres le land moreau la
consécration de yolande moreau la yo yo
des deschiens césar de la meilleure
actrice devant audrey tautou et césar du
premier film pour quand la mer monte
elle y interprète une propre personnage
en tournée
merci beaucoup
mathieu amalric et dans le même esprit
d'exception culturelle le césar du
meilleur acteur est allé à mathieu
amalric pour rois et reine d'arnaud
desplechin il avait vos concurrents
daniel auteuil
qu'est ce que cela me plairait de jouer
dans des
gros films
et en privilégiant des films
indépendants face à des gros budget les
professionnels du cinéma ont donné un
aspect inattendu à cette cérémonie
trentenaire